all right so we'll set up the context so
this is a how to train with Joe makos
embryonic so I use the term
embryonic to note that it's not the way
you apply
it
um the great distinction here is that a
lot of people think that you block in
makos and that's just not true and so
for
example uh if I push his sword around
and he goes to Kitty G you'll see a lot
of people block and that that that won't
work I don't have the mechanical
advantage to make that work okay that's
not an application of that it's a young
young
Clash um it's inconsistent with iido
it's just wrong does everyone do it yes
but they're wrong okay uh
what I what the an application time is
Bo I'm hitting it in admidst its attack
okay why can you train embryonically and
why should you you'll see if you do that
at higher speeds beginners just can't do
it okay you need to develop skills and
what usually happens when you push
someone outside their skill is they do
survival techniques and we'll slow down
their application Phase lookss like this
you see and they're trying to do that
the downside of that is that violates
weapon fighting so there's two two basic
rules in weapons fighting and especially
in iido that has an iy aspect to it I
try to make contact with that weapon
somewhere amidst whatever it's doing and
then I stay stuck to it I generate an
Ike adhesion wherever I lose the IE
adhesion I I follow the weapon okay
that's just a standard uh weapon tactic
you you do do it in in body art but it's
not as relevant in my opinion because
there's leeway uh if you brush my face
with a jab I'm still in the fight but
you cut out my eye I'm not in the fight
okay so um just so those who don't know
it for example let's say I make contact
and he goes around I'm following the
weapon do you see that would be one
strategy
um if he in this case I don't have
contact with the weapon so I have to now
use the other strategy and that is that
I remained or I I fuse my defense and my
offense so as I'm working for that
attack I'm covering myself as I'm
starting to follow the weapon so I don't
have contact but you can see see I'm
shielding myself because his his K his
I'm sorry his Kitt could come low boom
down on the leg you won't know that
because you don't have contact with it
okay so you have to Shield yourself as
long as possible until you can identify
oh he's coming over the top boom and
that's when I would hit it so if we look
maybe from here stay there camera maybe
a little over here
and you now look what my Joe is doing
you'll notice that it's covering my body
as it's trying to figure out what his
weapon is doing so my defense is
canceling out angles until I know
exactly what his weapon is doing boom
this way boom so I could cover the low I
can cover the medium and I can cover the
high
hence why you can't go like this this
only work works because you knew he was
coming High
okay so I need to know how to cover my
body but it doesn't mean I'm blocking my
body okay so we work like this you could
set it up from here there's no reason
why you
can't and now this stops in training
this stops being an natural sword cut
and it becomes the angle that I use to
teach me that Fusion of offense and
defense so I move to the right my my
weapon comes up my weapon comes up in
that same shielding
geometry okay this will be progression
one give the
Q find The
M bring your weapon up in that same
Fusion angle defle of deflection angle
of
attack
okay let's try progression one okay so
as I come around you have your outer rim
concept right so you don't want to
defend things outside your outer rim so
my right elbow in particular but you
could is never going to go way outside
my outer rim there's no need to defend
anything out here with that okay so pay
attention my elbow comes up my shoulders
line when I when I do the
movement likewise if I bring my elbow in
then I didn't Shield that shoulder okay
so a lot of people game this part and
they kind of just go like here like that
no I don't know what he's going to do so
I gain I I keep my elbow in on that Yang
line and do the
movement make yourself smaller so my my
base is going to lower lower so that the
bottom part of my weapon the elbow on
this side is following the same rule so
it's not going to go out it's not going
to come
in I'm I shrink my target Zone as I move
boom okay so to continue this embryonic
training he will lower because it's not
a sword cut and I'm not blocking it but
it's going to give me the elements for
progression
two so I'm one elbows are inside my
outer rim I make myself small
boom second detail you're not fighting
the
weapon so don't look over here the fight
is over
here foot Spine Center and in tension is
on
him elbows on your young line low Orient
towards
him okay try it add those details one
more detail on progression one is your
hands okay my my rear hand the right
hand in this case is my power hand okay
so as I move
over doing all that it is going to
remain grip and roll all the way to
cover the
whole my whole body but also for a
progression too to bring as much power
into progression
two I'm not blocking so I don't need
this hand to be closed okay and in fact
closing it violates your striking
principles so if I was going to punch
him I don't flex my fist right from the
whole time I don't move very fast my
fist is pretty loose until boom right
before contact then you'll have that
fist formation okay so same thing here
boom right hand close close complete the
cycle of action go all the way to here
other hand I'll leave open to put
tension with that closed grip is to
bring tension throughout the rest of the
body and that would slow me down at
application timing Okay so that fix your
hands progression two so we come
around again this is not a cut but right
now it's teaching me the Mind where I
need to be how far out
okay and that means that when we make
contact he's not trying to finish a cut
he's not a cut because this is not a
block I should never have I should never
let that contact here happen at
application phase this incorrect okay
this is embryonic training phase so he's
going to leave his sword at that
complimentary angle and in progression
two what I'm going to do is not push the
contact point so here the yin Yong
access I'm not going to push it I'm not
going to move it I'm not going to move
it I'm going to go around it so my job
is to bring the weapon to Bear keep
contact neither going oh I came
off oh I'm moving it I keep contact he
stays there and I go around it and then
down to the tuba where I'm in range for
the wrist
strike there he stops he doesn't keep
falling I go around it the left hand
will start to close I'm on the other
side
boom come to the other side
camera added
details is I'm going to make sure that
my power hand is underneath the majority
of my mass so right underneath my
Center not back not
forward
and then secondarily I'm going to make
sure my Mass is over my power hand so as
this hand starts to
drop I'm going to put my weight on this
hand you can see how I'm getting over
the top of it it's under me but I'm over
the top of it let's go back a little
here it's under me but I'm on the side
of it okay I'm want to be over the top
of
it
can can I move from here yes I can move
from there if you can't move from there
that's another issue that's on you okay
go okay so what this rotating cross is
doing you see this is where I want to be
and I'm training
myself to do
that going to move it
over then come
here I'm not going to move it this way
and then come
here I'm not going to
separate and then do any of those either
okay so if you
watch if I have my weapon here and you
picture that point in
space I'm not going to go forward with
it because I'm trying to defend myself
as as long as possible watch what
happens to my angles of defense and went
forward okay as I go forward my head
starts to be
uncovered if I take that point in space
and I move it this
way I start to uncover the left side of
my body
okay so in application Phase there's no
cross that ever makes contact but
energetically in terms of attacking
angles and defending angles I keep that
cross in place so I keep that point in
place and you can see the third joob by
my hands is still shielding my
body and I have another defense here
that I'm behind the weapon you do that
all the time in iido it's just one line
yeah but it's enough
okay and that's what you're training
here
one
two
no
no keep it there soft around you're now
in that other defensive angle that I now
attack with
boom
[Music]
different
different go from one guard to the other
guard boom and then attack with it
okay try it again okay so in application
Phase as you come around and you boom
you hit here how far do you go down is
dependent upon when you've captured his
Center you you'll feel his Center you'll
feel the check of the feet and you'll
feel the the projection the faster
everything's going the less movement you
have to do but this is training this
embryonic training so I like people to
train for all the way way down to the
bottom okay uh and how soon do you
capture someone's feet is not only a
matter of how fast you're going but what
is their internalization skill so if he
can reconcile a lot of energy I probably
have to go deeper into my action cycle
okay so I need to have the skill of
being able to go all the way to the
ground if I needed to okay so that's
what we're doing here one two I'm going
to come all the way down all the way
down boom all the way and still feel his
Center okay if if for him to reconcile
more we're on the ground okay sensei
used to make us go to the ground
sometimes but I have to feel his body so
this is progression three around boom I
still feel his
feet detail I'm not in his hands only
I'm not just hitting his hands
here okay it's going to go into his
Center so don't just aim on his hands
and try to get his hands try to get his
hands you're in his Center so boom
should have a projection energy that
causes some displacement that is your
Yin energy for Ed me and again if you
don't have internal skills you've never
experienced them you're like why is he
jumping that's not again that's not on
me that's on you go go learn these
skills go experience them it's just a
rebounding energy if You' seen a ball
bounce cool that's it don't sit there
and look at the bouncing ball and go
impossible okay so that's our
progression three one two I still doing
the cross thing boom I'm in his body I
should feel his feet at a minimum if you
can take it into a
center okay where you get some sense
that oh I'm projecting across the
sagittal
plane all right here we go progression
three so uh detail on progression
three
um it's a yinong art and the way that it
is designed is that you have to have
both elements you don't ever go left arm
is Yin always right arm is Young always
and nor would you ever have too Yin or
Too Young you you wouldn't have that
either okay so if he's up top came
around my hands don't move
together do you see that this is very
common but if you pay attention you'll
violate the rules of progression too you
move your hands together you're moving
the weapon even if you drop around the
other side I'm starting to drop I'm
starting to come off of it you see so
you're like okay I'm not push I'm not
going to push it Dave all right don't
push it but bring your hands together
the weapon's going to come off together
okay if you pay attention the right hand
is moving left hand has not moved yet
you see
that right hand move left not and
eventually it starts to move
behind right close left open you see
right is power hand as we're coming
around
boom I hit and at this point there's no
more power here there's still a little
rotation here is is entering its Yin
face it'll roll
over this is entering its Yang face boom
so the left hand does come into play yes
this is a beginner mistake you use your
left
hand but this also begin a mistake where
you're not using the left hand and it's
just the right hand they're going to
yinong and that means you're going to
face so look for that at the end B your
left hand has power on it
okay there is power on the left hand so
I'm On Top okay all right try